I thought the joke would be guys just so
you know somebody pulls a gun it's good
luck means you guys never getting
divorced you guys this is the equivalent
of a bird pooping on you in
Italy want to give a shout out to our
sponsor
jamesallen.com jamesallen.com is the
online destination for designing a
customized engagement ring that he or
she will love more easily than you ever
thought possible and saving up to 50%
compared to traditional stores get 25%
off your order when you go to
jamesallen.com and use the code DPT
that's code DPT jamesallen.com for 25%
off jamesallen.com hey townies welcome
to another episode of people Town
population you population Lee Jamie Lee
welcome to the show oh so good
people want to put a Curtis on the end
of your name c probably godam it thank
you I appreciate that she's having a
Resurgence though can we just say well
you could have an Alum I I have a bone
to pick so I was really appreciating I
she was kind of sliding back you're like
how dare you jam Lee come to the Fort
I'm just kid you ride some of that jet
stream that Jamie Lee jet stream you
could you could have an album just
called courtesy and it's Jamie Lee
courtesy
but don't you don't put it that way but
it's just called courtesy and see if any
it's just you doing and then when people
like sign off to like thanks again for
here guys Jam Lee courtesy is the album
oh my God or courtesy I put I put my
middle name on my Instagram because I
was like I was just like oh the like the
search results are so conflated with Jam
Lee Curtis and then I was like is that
douchi now I'm like a three name what is
your middle name Amanda j i the most '
80s name Jamie Amanda
we get
it yeah there's no like there no no
Jamie being born right now no Jennifers
no Debbies there's no Crystal oh I love
a crystal Lisa has anyone naming their
kid Lisa these days I feel like I will
say Lisa feels quite Timeless but I I
will say I don't know any new Lisa I
feel like mid 80s to mid99s is where
Jenna really had her Heyday Jenna a lot
of your Jenna Christa um so we before we
jump into the stories and we got dumb
stories which is why we invited you here
we got to break this stuff down and
thank God you're here uh we have to
reminisce and talk just briefly about
one of our favorite bits that we ever
did involving you and with us what was
it for it was for the VH1 was it the O
Awards or it was like an all night
24-hour thing that we were hosting yes
or no is VH1 still a channel yes I'm
going to you know that for sure no I
maybe it's just has an online presence
and I might just be on on Facebook it
also might completely be up and running
it could be also it could it could
honestly go either it could it could be
done or it could be the best it's ever
been I really wouldn't know the
difference like a demo that we are so
far away from he's watching it every day
out Lo 70 to 80 year olds it's an us
thing not a
them okay so you guys
are in Time Square at the TRL Studios
and we were Jay and I were hosting like
24 hours do we do all 24
I think I remember this this was like
2012 2013 back when it was cool it was
right after we had met I think I
remember you guys going to do this so we
went there we met the Jonas Brothers and
wrote a bit with them Quest love did a
bit with him and Andrew WK we did a bit
with Janine we did a bit with Jody
Lennon was so funny she this B but the
bit we did with Jamie that we will
always remember in just like the most
fun way is Paris Hilton was humongous
back then and we thought how funny would
it be if Jamie played the daughter of
the Hyatts like the Hyatt Hotel this is
already great what was your energy what
was your what was your like rank to
yourself that's a great question what
was
it titled and thought you were great
were you L status she know her parents
wanted her to [__] it up more to to up
business for high their killing them in
terms of like the Paris Hilton like like
this was helping the Hilton brand and so
they're like we're our daughters out and
it up and a little like I don't know if
that's what I want to
do yeah now it's coming back to me
that's right that's right I don't know
if that's what I really want I don't
know if that's who I am but my parents
said it and I have to do it and being a
member of the Hyatt family and we're
like can you tell us any Hyatt specials
I can tell you about some of the
specials that I can give you you were so
great so funny wait do we have like
video of this I need see it where can we
see it like maybe after V burned down
like did VH1 burned down uh it was so so
funny and you were so great CU we had
only known you as a standup and we
didn't know we loved what you were doing
we were just like I hope she can I hope
she can pull this off and then we were
in it and we're like having so much fun
in the middle of this thing you forget
that you're doing a bit that's what he
always said that we always said about at
midnight there were moments we'd be
doing it and we're like forgot there was
an audience forgot that we were shooting
a TV show we done that with live like
we've done live dumb people towns you
forget that the audience is out there
well listen there's a lot of dumb out in
this world Jamie are you ready to help
us break it down and try and figure try
and like make sense of it or I've been
I've been ready my whole life godamn I
love it love it I got the first story
this is sent in by Matthew fredman at
not not your average mat I love this guy
so we have a bunch of people that s it's
not AVG right no not a yeah oh he sent
yeah so our so we have we said this in a
couple episodes tell tell these people
so dumb boots on the ground what you do
is if you're still on X we are too or
Twitter you've gone over to calling it
call it Twitter I'm calling it hey it's
the Sears Tower and it's [__] Twitter
fine Twitter I got I had a little bit of
a chill when you just casually called it
X so look at my reaction who right
you're like you in if someone calls it X
they're paying for a blue check I was
trying no I was trying because I don't
know if people even know what Twitter is
any felt very
weird can someone get Jamie a coat God
damn it so anyway on threads on threads
so on no so you what you do is you uh
it's # dump people toown I wonder we
could try friends I don't know
everybody's on what you like to call we
have an order here in like # Dume toown
Daniel vankirk scolar brothers and it
lets us know who sent in the story first
and we were trying to sometimes like as
we put these stories together like we're
so many months back now we're still
calling through all of them thank you to
those who send them in uh and then we'll
let you know and we'll read your name on
the show and so not your average M
Matthew fredman uh all right this this
headline is just fabulous Indian
official suspended after he drains
Reservoir to retrieve phone he dropped
while taking self what a dick wow I mean
if you've got the power to drain a
reservoir for Goldblum you you were so
preoccupied with whether or not you
could you never asked yourself whether
or not you should this guy was like Yeah
from uh Jurassic
Park also he just says that casually
which a metaphor for AI by the way what
yeah yeah that is true so the guy
obviously holds some a position within
the city to drain a reservoir because he
wants his phone he was taking a selfie
of him at the res but the time you drain
it then it's it's done it it's so done
like you can't put it on rice from it
the amount of rice you would need for a
reservoir worth of water you can't even
put it on basmati rice this is India
godamn it streets to New York I said
this the first time I went to New York
it does not matter how long it could be
2 weeks since it's rained there is water
in the gutter in New York I don't it
does not I don't care where you are
there will be water in the gutter it it
will if you drop a phone even in one of
those puddles gutter water you it's a
50/50 so there's [__] on his phone that
he doesn't want someone to find out
about right my mind didn't even go there
but 100% 100% that's the only reason you
need to know it's not recoverable wow
okay yeah cuz I was there was definitely
sort of a a blank spot where I was like
but why would you just buy a new phone
yeah but then I was like maybe I don't
know enough about like iPhone value like
maybe bones the bones of it maybe
there's
you resell yes
exactly but yeah no it's definitely
salacious New Deli it's just one nude of
him but he's that he's that scared he's
like sitting on all I don't know what he
does this government official he's a
government official that's all it says
in India sitting on a stack of
government paper was likeing ITT
Reynolds in it so he has been suspended
from his job after ordered it's the
reservoir the water we might need yeah
that like in India I'm assuming they
need it I guarantee someone's like and
why are we doing this and that person
got fired right he ordered a water
reservoir to be drained so he could
retrieve his smartphone which dumb move
for smartphone not very smart also if it
was if there is anything incriminating
out which I love this which is why I'm
going to go with it uhhuh this is a
great way to tell everybody there's how
important your phone no one knows it's
in the reservoir except you there there
is definitely like a bra
to believing that people know where your
phone is at all or care or care cuz we
all it's it's either us or Comics were
hanging around in a restaurant or
whatever where someone who doesn't deal
with people who have this comedy disease
we be like don't do that and you'll say
no one here knows us no one here's going
to remember this don't who cares right
this guy needs to be taken down a peg
yes several pegs all the pegs so here's
the detail that I find interesting okay
so he he was he ordered them to drain
the so he could retrieve his smartphone
which he had dropped while taking a
selfie who needs to know that that's why
while he was taking a selfie Just
Dropped In The Water we hit a bump I
dropped in the no one needs to know was
like taking pictures of the reservoir
just to make sure levels were good like
you couldn't make it a work thing I was
doing a city for the city how is this
for the city I also think it it it shows
like his lack of sort of like
understanding of techn olog because
there's a timer on that thing you don't
you should if you need to get a photo
you set it up set it up you go 3 seconds
or 10 seconds you choose your seconds
and then you take the F so it also makes
him look double dumb because he can't
there's no 10 seconds longer than
waiting for your phone time to go
on that is such that is you could do so
much and no slower with the 3 seconds
yes oh 100% yeah yeah or faster sorry I
faster faster yes I'm like okay that
definitely wasn't through and so you're
like and you're like fine you know what
I'm done [__] with three because
you're not giving time we're going to 10
and then during 10 you read a book and
go through a
relation it's like the wave planet on
Interstellar like years are passing oh
yeah time is a flat circle on the 10
you're like I don't even want this
picture anymore all right the three
seconds like one to three also can I say
his excuse for what he's doing little
bit of Taming of the sh thou doth
protest too much if you're telling me a
lot about why you can't come into work
today or what happened it's because it's
something else gu that's the guiltiness
yeah he's guilty all right food
inspector maybe that's his government
job I would assume Rajesh vishwas
dropped his Samsung smartphone Let It Go
Galaxy Note Let It Go oh although there
is people I guarantee there are Townes
even before and definitely now going
those are the most waterproof phones
like cuz we will never know that's the
thing too you can do whatever you want
to as Samsung it can make you a cake I
will never know can
so we went on this like crazy hike
around the M Blanc with our buddy Mark
and his friend he has a bunch of friends
who work at Google and one of them had a
Google pixel thing it took the best
pictur have you ever been at a concert
and seen someone with a great Sam it is
unreal I've never seen I've never seen
okaying all right so he maybe he wanted
it maybe he needed a Samsung in the
kahera dam in the central Indian state
of chadis Scar you got this
did your best you did your best the
times of India don't turn around well uh
oh the chat isar all right the times of
indiaan newspaper reported this so of
India feels big big feels like a big
vishwas uh first asked local divers as
local divers to jump into the reservoir
to find his device so now he's making
other people do being the same people
who rescued a team of Thai soccer
players to find your phone pH right
sounds like should have been wasn't yeah
thank you the kids in the cave yes those
un literally the most unbelievable
documentary I've ever seen
unbelievable okay well I have to ask you
then you you've watched last breath yes
the documentary on Netflix I I watched
it twice I tell people all the time I go
I go I want you to watch it and not just
because I want you to watch it because I
want you I I'm tell this is the way I'm
going to get you to call me because as
soon as it's over you have to talk you
have to talk about it my you need to
talk about you need to break it down I'm
going to see you told me to watch the
Avalanche One fromed Alive buried about
Lake Tahoe Avalanche 1983 it's on Amazon
you wonderful you got to buy it you have
to buy it buy buy okay then I don't care
she's like then I don't get give
Shar what happened to them they got
buried in Tahoe I think I know I think I
I think I learned a lot from the title
there so tell you what Jamie because I
care about you when you order your
Amazon stuff tell them to bring It 2
Days Later they'll give you enough
credit to where eventually you'll just
get it for for free is that right do you
guys ever do that no Amazon will tell
you like like we free free two-day
delivery and let's say that's a Friday
and they'll go or we can deliver
Saturday and give you a 150 Digital
Credit and those digital credits are
used towards anything you would r150
digital usually sometimes they're more
but they'll or even a dollar but they'll
go towards anything you rent on Amazon
to watch I'm never getting my [__]
delivered on time ever again it's just
fre that's great to know so my son got a
a Amazon gift card for like his like
10th birthday and I've used those to buy
things for myself all the time like I'm
L he know he doesn't listen to this
podcast it comes out in the watch but it
does make me feel so good that you've
seen last breath so many people haven't
seen it just that opening the opening
credits I mean love last bre yeah last
breath you that's last uh after initial
efforts to retrieve his smartphone oh
this is why he said uh claimed it
contains sensitive government data oh
really so we're so we're up to two
excuses dickpic that's dickpics you had
an with someone in the other in the
government uh after initial efforts to
retrieve his smartphone failed he asked
for the reservoir to be emptied using
diesel pumps what this guy that's some I
don't know what that means but it makes
it sound worse it's terrible you're
putting your pumping it sounds like just
incredibly environmental horrible like
the worst for just for his phone over
the next 3 days how many liters of water
were pumped out of the reservoir what's
your you lived by one what's it what
your average was I mean I want to say 50
million liters of water that's a good
guess give us a guess I don't know any
sort of ler
million I'm going to go oh my God I'll
go 10 million tell me leers all right
get your answers crazy I probably would
have just said seven buckets if Randy
had gone so shot it to your ham radios
he got rid of more than 2 million liters
of water you were right to me in the
millions right to me in the million but
I was a little high up there which is is
enough to irrigate how many acres of
land now that we're getting into this
goddamn act question I want you guys to
know we want you to come out of this
podcast 2 million liters of water could
irrigate how many acres 50 acres oh No 5
acres of land no 50 AC 50 acres dud you
were in the thousands and I'm saying
that to be nice it I'm I'm going to go
4,000 Acres yeah I'm going to go higher
just cuz I'm you're feel sassy yeah I'm
going to say seven 7,000
uh it could irrigate at least so you
guys could be right 1,500 Acres all
right fine during India's scorching
summer local media reported so he's
doing this in a bad time in a drought
yeah cuz he didn't you don't give a [__]
I don't care when you're draining in the
water you don't give a [__] I don't have
I should have gotten this video I'm
sorry I didn't track it down we'll link
it in the YouTube uh in videos that went
viral on social media Aon if you can
find these videos and Link it uh vuas
not guys just Google is seen sitting
under a red umbrella
as diesel pumps run to drain water from
the res what you doing bud sipping a p
did a good job yeah guys you missed a
spot over there have you found it yet um
he told local media that the water in
the reservoir was unusable for
irrigation oh so this is where it
becomes water cannot be unusable for
irrigation for drinking maybe nonpotable
Water Irrigation it's just
water uh that he had received permission
from a senior official to which senior
official who told one over there Dave
there is no Dave in that office why are
you saying Dave that's not you don't
know the office do you know which office
but this is a common problem people just
don't verify okay they don't check this
is where D people Town ready oh this is
where this where this is we've already
been there J training a reservoir to get
your phone you dro the smartphone was
eventually retrieved and it did not work
but wouldn't even start because it was
water logged thank
you [__] wow authorities later suspended
vishwas after he was just suspended
widely criticized for wasting Water
Resources the video of him went viral
and so India is one of the most water
stressed countries and at extreme
temperatures has led to severe water
scarcity causing crops losses this could
be the death of not just people but
years of crops so he could get his smart
this
where yeah his broken phone this what
doesn't happen but this is where like
Samsung goes hey guys you know what
we're bringing in like they don't have
to do it all but like we'll refill the
water yes and we like it's not on us but
uh you know because he had Samsung we
just we caught a stray in this because
as a commercial can we use this goad
you're going to give millions of people
water [__] stream it live and then
Dan Apple comes in and we're like we're
giving your four-year-olds job so in
your face well I didn't like that end of
that sentence but I like them doing
something good got uh all right there's
Story number one there you go uh I think
uh rand's got Story number two uh when
we come back we'll plug what we're doing
we'll let you know how you can support
Jamie Lee and uh this is dumb people
Town we're off and running with the dumm
don't go
anywhere hey guys welcome back to the
show so nice to have you here Jamie Lee
is with us the great Jamie Le with we're
going to find out what she's got going
on but first news let you guys know
what's happening with us doing uh a show
that Jamie's going to be a part of oh
you're going to do it have you done tag
it before no it's so fun so Jamie they
gave me one that made the album yes on
stage in Austin you do your set janire
off to the side while you're doing your
set not doing un interrupting at all you
do your set janire writing little uh
tags for the jokes that you're doing
then we stage afterwards and we're like
okay we love this bit here's a bunch of
the green The Green Room moment happens
we pitch it to you on stage and you can
take them with you and people a writer's
room it's the Green Room that's so fun
right it's so fun so yeah and useful
I'll take TS take tags all day it's also
crazy cuz it's the only show where you
know at least two of the comics are
watching your
set it's true that's so true you're like
like you stayed for that whole show for
the whole show watch it is great when
you do have the time and you go I'm just
going to [__] hang can I tell you I
like to get to shows early I I don't
know when this anxiety will go away but
I for some reason need to like see other
people go up to be like oh yeah that's
how you do stand up I get to the Improv
like like I want to say 20 minutes
before it even starts sometimes and I'm
just watching three sets before me what
you guys are doing in this show tags of
like places I would go with them almost
like gets me like I'm already in Step
plus with the audience I it nothing
makes me cringe more than when I've seen
two Comics talk to the guy in the red
shirt and then a third comic to it and
the audience knows this guy's been
talked to a lot CU there's nothing the
biggest fear at least for for me
everybody wants to know the audience
knowing something the comic doesn't know
and and when you see that that's another
great reason to get there early if
you're going to do crowd work or talk to
people like this guy's already been so
you know what we're going to do we're
going to put you up later in the show
just you can see how it works and get a
feel for that but no like people I love
being later in a line Mark Norman came
and saw did saw the show did the set and
then he stayed and watched the rest of
the show cuz it's it ends up being kind
of fun to try and guess where we're
going to jump in and what we're going to
do and fun I sometimes theme shows like
I get nervous I'm like oh not going to
be good at the the game they're trying
to play SP a wheel then you've got a the
fun of this show is you just come up and
do your set you just do what you do and
we have to we we're on the spot really
for the whole night it's on us and it's
but it's fun great exercise great things
so we're doing that at the belly room uh
on the 13th of September you'll be on
that and then the 18th we're doing it at
Largo uh Fortune fster Pat and Oswald
and two huge guests that we are not
announcing but we will just tell you
they announcing you should be there they
are big and we're announcing you should
should be there for that usually the the
belly room show sells out and it's so
much fun and let's sell this Largo one
out coming back to do the belly room
again on October 18th and we're doing a
show at The Bourbon Room
supercars.net
to be me captioning being like yeah
taking my photos off of my Instagram and
putting on theirs and they got tons of
followers it was very stressful that is
stressful when they you're like you're
better at this than I am I was like oh
you're actually good at this maybe I
should just like meet you and turn over
my social media to you hire them then
they had to but the only way to get that
account shut down and you can't take it
over you have to just shut it down so I
was like where are those F the F anyways
point is it's at really Jam Lee and my
um I have a link on there to my upcoming
tour dates great come see her live she's
is going to be so good and maybe she'll
use some of the tags we give her on the
13th should we jump into the Second
Story sent in by our good buddy Jake
grony at Jake thanks buddy you ready for
this this is fun this is always
enjoyable we'll find out here we go feel
wedding venue owner points gun at
Florida newlyweds during reception get
out uh that's someone who didn't hold
their piece yeah what could happen guess
or they are holding their piece but they
didn't holding a your piece is p e a c e
and they didn't realiz during I have not
planned a wedding I said Florida I have
not planned a wedding but what could
happen I just officiated one I did too
this past weekend how funny were you
funny I was pretty funny of course you
were but I also was like you have to you
have to be serious because it's Bal they
had a lot of things they wanted said
which I took as a like oh this just
makes it easier for me but I I opened
with a joke and and then stuck with
their whole thing oh man it's so fun to
have a comedian to to have a to go to
the gun during the reception have you
even fully settled you think happened
have you settled up I'll tell I'll tell
you exactly what happened I'm curious to
if you think what if you know what I
know exactly what happened meth okay the
owner of the thing did a whole load of
meth and got paranoid this this where
you're like we got this place for so
cheap hun and then you're like find out
why like oh you do have to deal with
Carol right I think you get what it's a
great deal everything's included but
she's bringing her alligator she's she's
a bit much some would
say all right a Florida couple's
marriage got off to a rocky start when
the owner of their reception venue
pointed a gun at them and ordered
everyone to get out after a row over the
music I knew it I was going to say music
oh my God I was going to say music
because well I don't know about Florida
but in California having gotten married
that anything Outdoors has to be shut
down by 10 p.m. they're very strict are
you are you ready for a great music
complaint story from my from my wedding
and ours uh no from my wedding though
you didn't you don't even know this
story this is great uh someone came up
to us from who who I guess the wedding
plan or someone said the FR hey someone
is complaining about the loudness of the
music at this thing and it wasn't past
our time or anything and I'm like who
the [__] is complaining about the
loudness of the music they're like that
woman over there and I was like oh
that's my wife's
stepmom that
is that yes that is worth it for those
listening he did a little kick a little
high kick after that and I think it's
warranted that was great so 10 p.m. is
right so it was Sunday night when we
were doing our wedding or Saturday
Sunday night I can't I think it was
Sunday uh we were doing our wedding and
um at 10 p.m. and they wanted to go just
a little bit longer but where we did it
on kind of in Malibu area where we had
at the B A Bay Club where we did it uh
there were complaints up the road from
someone who lived up the road and that
person who was complaining about it
Michael Richards really and you know he
never suffered anything after that his
career was smooth how did you know it
was just be but it could have be content
of he ran in through the door and he
went quickly through the door and he was
like all right insane video posted by
Jonathan Campo the DJ
and cousin of the Bride okay shows this
is my favorite C Martin movie cousin of
the Bride uh shows the
i% watch that mie I would watch that I
don't I don't
even know it's already my favorite movie
actually I've decided and I know that it
goes straight to streaming I that does
not affect quality expectation for me
Father the bride would probably go
straight to streaming now now is
horrifying also Cheaper by the Dozen
straight to streaming Godfather bride is
so [__] good my God cousin of the
Bride shows the iate man W man waving a
weapon and shouting at the terrified
guest Thursday can you imagine you show
up at this thing and like I hope we
haven't paid cuz if we haven't settled
up for the venue yet it's we're not
paying now you're suing his ass night at
SEO farms in Southwest Ranches okay so
it's the Farmland so those you should be
able to have late you to wake up the pig
freaking Rave in the middle of thank you
go go loud go hard Campo said he begins
to wave at everybody in the party
telling them all to get out get out get
out Campo told
WPLG but he's not saying about the time
he's saying about music about adding
that that the Mayhem erupted during the
last song of the night but I think it's
nice the DJ told wsvn do you guys think
it was
[__] true story at the wedding I
officiated I waited for all the olds to
leave get at I go up to the DJ like play
[__] and I go you want to see this place
go nuts I hand him some cash of course
you did and I go play this just play W
please right and uh cuz our like in our
friend group we we play it every time
we're at a bar it is we love it I play
[__] and he goes I'm sorry and I go and I
go I go buddy play W he goes he he was I
could tell he was a good dude he opens
up the papers he has it says do not play
all caps highlighted the only song is w
and I took a picture of it and sent it
out our friend group and people lost
their minds it's the greatest so he he
goes you I got to give you your money
back and I said no you're doing a great
job keep it you don't take a [__]
once you've handed it you don't [__]
take a back what if you you gave him a
20 said just give me
10 oh my God he's like I have no change
he's like well go get some uh you
denying my request has I should have
said my w went dry when you told me that
you weren't going to play my song so
give me my money back hey buddy macaroni
in a pot my w is I should have been like
fine turn everything off give me the mic
I'll sing it I also at at a wedding also
in Wisconsin other best friend I got
drunk and they were doing a deal where
the DJ was having a song it was like
Sweet Caroline and he was like people
like singing along so he gets to me and
I belligerently but not belligerently
like real like putting it on I grab kind
of his wrist and hand over his hand and
I just go I have a right to see my
children a good bit the next day such a
good bit you brought up a custody disp
in the middle of someone's resp in the
middle of sweet Carol everyone else is
Bop I have a right to see my Amanda who
married one of my best friends Bradford
the next day Amanda Amanda goes I saw my
mom this morning we're at all like a
brunch deal right and she goes so um the
best man's going through some sort of
real bad divorce huh there was a whole
table of olds that were like that guy is
going through it saw I wait for the olds
to leave wait for the olds to leave and
then I do but that sentence tells an
entire story I have a right to see my
children so here's what I love Dan I'm
picturing Dan because he's not at a show
he doesn't have to do standup he's not
like out in that fight he's just at a
wedding which is a it's a secure that
joke was for you that joke is for you
and I love that you're just like I'm
just going to get drunk because I'm here
with friends I'm just going to get that
means you were in your own Zone which I
love I bet you killed your best man
speech you also so you're on a bit of a
high like I'm kind of the king of the
wedding do anything now and like the
aunts and uncles can be like hey like
they have something to talk to like when
you do a cruise ship so Mayhem erupted
during the last song that night DJ told
wsvn that a worker at the venue ordered
him to turn off the music over fears of
noise complaints then spilled a drink on
his equipment even though he had turn
the music down so that might have been
an accident the person could have been
drunk why is the worker have a drink
what's he doing yeah what is he by this
time the entire listen I I'm the head
dishwasher here
he guys are [__] great you guys are
[__] great and I can tell you're in
love this A happy couple that's what it
is we get so many weddings here and I
looked at you too and I was like you
guys have sex and you're in love and I
guy who keeps gesticulating with a full
drink like I've been here for 5 years
and I don't care I come from all the way
over there wait wait you the other hand
that's your drink hand it's the fullest
Martini ever olives the worst the worst
possible glass that allows the most a
champagne glass that's ice is coming out
of the drink that's how wildly he's
throwing it around who drank
this it's like in drop dead gorgeous
when the beer is just like fused to her
hand like he's like this my this is the
hand I use I'm sorry it just happens to
have drink in itating so by the time the
uh by this time the entire wedding party
is aware of what's going on Campo told
the outlet moments later the gun
wielding man whom Campo identified as
the owner of the venue showed up and
went ballistic get out get out don't
make me get out get out the man in the
yellow shirt is heard saying to a
terrifying footage as people flee if
this man in the yellow shirt if you
added a gun to Curious George and made
instead of man yellow hat Manny yellow
shirt with a gun who just kept
threatening people that's a better book
and a better M also what a [__] idiot
as with most things no gun is needed
none the good time of a wedding it hangs
so precariously on everybody being on it
like you know the bar is close enough to
the dance floor all that [__] that if
someone just walks in and starts yelling
get out get out it's going to ruin it
enough anyway you don't need the gun
yeah the gun is overkill yeah you just
come in and be the guy the GU Ru wedding
you have
lot yeah very clear job I have an idea
for you right now I'm going to speak it
out is the book again a
book these guys remember you told me
that you wanted me to write a wedding
book called I'll dance with your aunt
yeah I'll dance with your aunt or how to
make a how to how to make every wedding
the best wedding ever you should write
that book you should write that wrot a
wedding book I know you did you did yeah
this is but I feel like Dan is a good
followup we
should this is got to be the best
wedding guest ever your book was about
getting married right uh yeah and like
planning a wedding yeah but I feel like
to for it to be from the guest
perspective is very cool how to be the
best wedding guest ever Dan you could
write that book in probably four weeks
you would I am a good wedding guest no
but you know all the tricks of the trade
and the thing everything you just said
every story you have wait what's the
name of your book so people can get it
um it's called rediculous it's w i have
to spell it cuz it's such a weird word
but it's basic ridiculous but w d d
That's we D Amanda Amanda no it's called
ridiculous and yes I I stand by it I
read it again recently and I was like it
holds up I wrote it in 2016 you're
phenomenal writer and so funny all right
Camp said the man just started branching
a gun everywhere at everybody he put it
in my uncle now what if this was if it
wasn't a gun it was his penis he put it
in my uncle's face put it at my cousin
who got married the bride put it at her
head again W fer fit's penis waved it at
her husband's head way fun here 15 the
waving of the waving of he recounted
there's one Uncle at this buding that is
unfazed by a gun being put in his face
just keeps drinking he proba knows him
like oh that's my buddy D put it away
we're doing this again he's like Kobe
when Matt Barn started to throw a ball
in his why am I bra Perfect Analogy why
am I bracing myself to get shot all I
was doing was DJing my cousin's wedding
and trying to give her the Last Dance
the DJ added one woman I would never
recommend that yeah one woman is if
you're if you're the one getting married
you leave 45 minutes before the re's
over party lives in your mind forever
you never saw come up put it in the book
put it in the book put it in the book
hot tip I really like that that's right
one woman is her telling the unhinged
man she just wanted to grab her purse
honey leave it we'll get it later my
gun's in there this this sort of brings
up a larger thing cuz I feel like I had
this have you ever stayed in an Airbnb
when like the owner is on the property
MH and they kind of don't disclose that
in advance but they're kind of like
they're like we're just over there in
the side house and you're like oh okay I
guess that's supposed to be a comfort
cuz they're like yeah anything you need
they're we're right here and I'm always
a little like I don't you go and I feel
like that's kind of what's Happening
Here is like this person probably should
not have been on property there's
someone else managing the wedding venue
aspect of his property and then it's
like he's stuck around he stuck around
this happens in Wisconsin there are
literally Wisconsin bars that are
people's living rooms and so they'll get
to a point where they're like you guys
all got to go and you're like it's 9:45
but they're like we we're done but yes
exactly and and the araban people will
always always drop a line like we'll let
you know if we need milk and I'm like I
don't no I don't want to see you again
I'm living in a fake world where this is
my house pret you don't exist yeah I'm
pretending I own this I paid for you not
to be here so wed wedding guest and this
is I've never heard this name ever in my
entire life you should use this is your
Instagram name okay aixa aixa figuroa
called 911 that's a Carmen San
Diego uh was Asia Asia maybe that's Asia
Asia fig Asia was terrified I wasn't
sure if I was going to be going home
without a family
membership can't for this would be
nightmare fuelo described the incident
on Instagram where he posted the video
he said the bride the bride rented the
venue until what time what time did the
bride rent the venue until 1:00 a.m.
what do you think I want the bride to
say this so Dan if Dan was at this
wedding would make the joke gun to your
head was this the best wedding you've
ever no actually you know what I was
going to say I thought the joke would be
guys just so you know somebody pulls a
gun it's good
luck me you guys never getting divorced
you guys not this is the equivalent of a
bird pooping on your ital and it rained
you guys are going to be married forever
you guys that means your honeymoon's
going to be great yeah your kids are
going to turn out great and have a
fruitful you have a fruitful future be
fruitful and multiply hey wait so what
time do you you say one what do you say
I'm going to say like 11 what do you
think can I just ask a question we they
did we did not disclose what time this
happened no okay yeah yeah I'm going say
that's the next question I'm going to
I'm going to even say yeah midnight I'll
say midnight Midnight I say book till 11
book till 11 get your answers in town is
because she had rented the venue until
is it 10: p.m. 11:30 between you guys
between all right what an odd time but
the worker but the worker ordered the
event shut down around what time 11: you
say 11: and she she when do you think
it's 10 p.m. and I will say this I don't
like an early ending uh reception mhm
but if you are in this position 11:30 is
a weird time because then people go
should we just go to bed it's almost
midnight if you end at 10: everyone will
go to another bar and that's where
they'll get really crazy and they won't
[__] up they won't yeah put it in the
book put it in the book
D well I wrote a [__] book under peer
pressure but Jamie helped so it actually
was really good I gotes the forward to
your book writes the forward who's your
book agent can we
I
really forward to this book dance with
your aunt okay dance with your aunt I'll
dance with your aunt how to be the best
wedding guest ever Dan that's the
subtitle we're going to write J and I
will talk about it we going about I'm
going 10 10:00 is when he he showed up
and said turn down what wait the DJ is
doing last song I know that's the part
where I'm like G anyways but I because I
feel like this is just a weird town that
loves things to be on the 30s I'm going
to say a 10:30 okay town that loves it
on the 30s weather on the 30s what did
you say I said 11 WEA on the 30s I said
11 Last Call on the 30s get your answers
in Townes because he the worker ordered
the event to be shut down at 1050 p.m.
so you is but in my hour but you're
close whole numbers you got 40 more
minutes after an altercation he returned
with an armed man before I knew I was
staring down the barrel of his gun and
at that moment I saw his eyes I was
prepared to be killed and was coming to
terms that my children were about to
lose their dad you a little deep we get
it we get it we get it set the case to
put this guy I agree with him but you
frosted the cake twice DJ you're a DJ I
feel like you can't you can't make that
serious you're a DJ your life doesn't
mean anything anyway the DJ's like no
the DJ's like what was going through
your mind I felt like I was going to die
like he keeps hitting the horn right
like I feel like you can't make that Ser
of statement and then give Reveal Your
DJ name DJ was just remixed
I I I was about to cross fade off this
plan he just starts playing I will Sur
that great so he's I thought my kids
were never going to have a father said
DJ scribble Scrabble yeah that's great
is that really his name no oh put that
in the book put that in the book put
that in the book do your DJ oh my God
Man shows up at a with a gun at the
wedding before the end and I said and I
scared my own ality in life and I wi wi
wi wi wik it told him to get out anyway
said DJ sun power Right Said DJ
soulflower the man with the gun has been
identified as Miguel Rodriguez alisu how
old not only does this wrong he's in
breach of contract M how old is Miguel
Rodriguez albisu do you want to go first
TIG or last the man holding the gun at
the
end I'm going to say
60s pick a year okay 62 right 54 47 get
your answers in townies because I really
hope it's old and deranged and not young
and deranged 58 years
old right there okay so he okay state
record cited by the Miami her identify
Aliso as the corporate officer of SEO
Farms Nursery which has the same
volunteer Road address as the court list
says the man's home so he lives where
the nursery is called it called
Christian Sergio rafart that's a
hilarious name was o arrested in
connection with the incident and charged
with battery and resisting arrest he's
probably the guy who poured the drink on
the machine it just went from being like
an amazing event to the one you remember
for the rest of life to an event that
you're really going to remember for the
rest of your life for the wrong reasons
and they'll never get another wedding
there nor should they so you you you're
done dude you you finished the business
there the owner of the uh SEO Nursery
Farms told the outlet that they would
consult with their attorney before
commenting dude you're done and even
when you sell it the next owners have to
call it new owner Nursery like to just
get not even call it something else but
but people you just you're the
distancing you have to distance so hard
no one's going to ever crazy the
smallest thing that can ruin a wedding
and I'm going to say this straight to
cam the like a cash bar the smallest
thing that can ruin a wedding is I'm
just saying there's so little things
then this oh this is an enormous this
Norms that can ruin like a marriage our
friend we were at our friend's wedding
and his brother did the best man speech
and it was too long and also like not
funny and really personal and like we
came outside our friend just like was
ripping his brother a new ass can't
roast you can't roast with no jokes no
well so so our friend's brother got up
and spoke for way too long it was not
funny and then our we walked outside and
our friend was like what are you doing
what are you doing this tell this is
what I told people who are uh best men
made of h b put it in the book If you
roast youve immediately lost 75% of the
audience because half the people do not
know you and don't know him so they have
no context for that this is funny or
actually mean should be the people who
do know you and him at least half of
them wish you weren't doing this so you
go you're going for 25% of the audience
and those people are too drunk they're
the bad people well listen never roast
here you're going to write this you're
going to roast you have to have a roast
consultant you can't just free
roast you can only roast things that
have happened that day you cannot yeah
you cannot go too far back cuz I was at
a wedding where someone was roasting and
they were literally talking about the
groom masturbating at summer camp
already out I'm already out in front and
I was like the olds are there the olds
are there first of all and second of all
I was like why are we also what does
this have to do with the bride I'm sorry
bring it back it's about them and she is
part of them nothing better than a ma of
Honor or best man who starts with
they're probably going to wish they
didn't ask me to do this oh God they
already do right Jamie's like where's
the guy with the gun now yeah bring yeah
he's actually not so bad when you need
need him where is he when you need him
yeah uh all right that is Story number
two down the books Daniel's got the
third story hang on awesome wow uh and
we'll get to Story number uh three we'll
tell you what Dan's doing how to support
give us a little taste just a little
taste of what we're going to hear in
Story the law is stepping into social
problems but in a fun way okay great I
like it I love when the law gets fun uh
Jam Lee is with us buy her hilarious
wedding book uh which
isul ridiculous ridiculous and I have a
show on Netflix that's based on the book
called The Wedding coach oh [__] yeah
come on Jamie Lee everybody we'll be
right back and do the last segment
together this is so much fun as dumb
people
tell around
sound so I've been through the
engagement process Randy has as well
both you have done it once we've done it
once and I will say that when thinking
about what that experience was going
into the store you have someone who's
there you don't know anything you don't
know anything and they're like upselling
you all the time all the way you kind of
lose your agency when you're in the
store because they're like uh if you
care you want to go from this to this
and you want to go from this to this and
if you get lucky you've got somebody
who's like oh I got a guy but even then
it's like I don't know anything you're
like don't know where to start they like
we like this and then they're like no no
no this is what you should get and
before you know it you're in this whole
like sort of battle with this person at
the store who's trying to upsell into
some other thing you lose your ability
to be creative so what should people do
to avoid all of that they need to go to
jamesallen.com where you take control of
the cre process jamesallen.com is the
online destination for designing a
customized engagement ring that she or
he'll love uh more easily than you ever
thought it is so easy Dan you've been on
it you see it saving let me say this
saving up to 15% compared to traditional
St 50% so this is what I like about them
right you when you go in and you go to
the site you literally can go do you
want to go bu style do you want to go by
metal do you want to go by customizing
it from scratch from your own do you
want to start with a setting a diamond
lab created start with a gemstone like
they kind of you go through the process
of maybe something that you already know
and then get so many options you can
choose from over 200,000 certified
conflict free diamonds they've got both
Earth created and lab created it's just
the absolute it's the fastest growing
online retailer of engagement rings in
Diamond jewelie they've been a part of
over 200,000 engagements around the
world yours could be next Jay they have
a deal I want to tell our fans about
this right now you get 25% off your uh
order when you go to jamesallen.com and
use the code what Jay DPT that's right
that's the code DPT at James allen.com
for 25% off Dan what's the name James
allen.com code
dpd around sound
there's hey guys welome welcome back to
the show before we get to the final
story Daniel I know you have a very big
thing coming up on 1111 tell people
about that the ramp up to I am shooting
my special and simultaneously recording
it as my next album it's in Chicago
11-11 the Lincoln Lodge two shows the
night before if you want to make the
commute I'm in my hometown those shows
all of what I'm about to say those and
Rochelle in my hometown of Illinois in
Illinois are going to sell out as well
everything's at Daniel van.com I'm
headlining 10,000 laughs in Minneapolis
yuck Fest in Boston I'll be at
hilarities in Cleveland I'll be at the
White Rabbit in Louisville everything's
at Daniel van kirk.com there's about 20
cities up there between midp I'm doing a
week in Vegas on strip so great come out
everybody dan.com and if you know
WordPress I'll take the help help out
with his WordPress can't see all my
dates on the mobile version and that's a
definite problem you want to do the
story yeah yeah let's do it sent in by
double dipping Jake grony Jake gron on a
roll okay here's the headline
lawmaker I could this could be on like
your guys' set list you'd all be able to
do five minutes lawmaker wants to punish
ghosting I am all for that I think
that's genius 100% like 100% I honestly
don't even need to hear the rest of the
story I actually just F all three of us
agree Dan all you got to do is be like
text date next to text like chain
ongoing ongoing text time and date next
text then nothing nothing this
nothingness nothing after 2 weeks
there's a fine involved you find
community
service I say that as someone who
accidentally ghosts people all the time
because I am horrible at remembering to
text back I have and people I love but
if you had a punishment you're not even
talking about relationships I actually
what well first of all I was talking
about relationships but then I realized
it would even help me if there was a
fine because I would step up my game to
make sure that I'm replying to all the
texts yeah you can say it at the out
what how many unread texts do you have
on your phone Dan it's it's quite a lot
it's really open it up like we we were
we were on 127 over there her phone's
over there it's just more like people
think I'm mad at them because I didn't
respond it's that can I just say for the
record I we you un text has this
happened to you through me nope for the
record I we have wanted Jamie to be on
the show we knew that Jamie was going to
be on our taget show coming up and I was
going to ask her there do you want to
come and do people Town saw her face to
face in person get a date figure it out
right there I texted her yesterday and
was like Hey we'd love to have you on
the show I was going to ask you in
person but do you want to come texted me
right back said yes I can do it and
she's sitting right here so this is the
follow through let's give her credit
give her flowers that actually does feel
good cuz you're right I did I did step
it up yesterday came right back but also
you have to text back a few times in
order to even ghost so you've been set
up to be ghosted I mean when I set up a
lunch for hang out it's going to
go be sitting at
sweet I also pronounced it sweet grin
sweet I'll be sitting at tender
gr sweat GRS I mean so many I love my
sweat GRS I mean look it is awkward and
nobody likes to get it but just sending
someone um had a good time I just don't
think this is right for me I take care I
know that's not like enough flowers but
we beened is better than nothing
your once you send that you don't have
to respond to anything they send you Dan
I want her pronunciation of sweet je
sweet jeans oh sweet jeans guys have you
been jeans see to be the new Josh
safy was my was my what was it what is
it it's my muse I was just m uncut uncut
J yeah JS
[Music]
unut sweat of gr uh my favorite movie
was the grandma
have you guys have you guys seen fried
Grand Tomatoes fried Grand Tomatoes the
grandma the grandma I could have said
that in my normal voice still works
dating these days feels impossible ask
anyone and breaking up is so hard for
some that ghosting which uh for anybody
who needs this they wrote it here
ignoring someone calls and texts when
you've lost interest awful has become
the norm but a politician in the
Philippines is trying to make the act of
ghosting an emotional offense thank you
Manny Pacquiao uh I'm just reading what
they wrote here which is very like opet
M sorry fellow young adults our days but
it's everyone I have people in their 60s
I'm like text me back yeah right uh
sorry fellow young adults our days of
ignoring our problems until they go away
might be numbered representative aralo
TZ Jr atj he's doing something about it
the naed on this people's Coalition has
proposed a bill in the Republic of the
Philippines House of Representatives
that could criminalize the act of
ghosting or cutting off online
communication with another person M well
he proposed the bill and then they said
what are you going to do he never got
back he was absent for the he never
showed up for the vot he was absent for
the bro where are you and then he and
then when they all go to leave he barges
in and he goes see see how bad it feels
it's s it really stinks I was proving a
point the bill titled an act declaring
ghosting as an emotional offense you we
can punch we can tighten that up yeah
also emotional offense is like pretty
cool it you imagine texting that to
people you have emal how about Jam Lee's
new album Jam Lee emotional offender
emotional offender emotional offender
and then my title my little like
whatever the subtitle would be big tits
bad
attitude I have that shirt underneath
that it would be like The Grass Is
Always grer yeah there you goer gr it
just keeps going it's like the chart at
the eye doctor just which line can you
read small yeah you need a magn you have
to keep doing this to open up to read
the B right one news Philippines uh
Likens ghosting to emotional cruelty
arguing that ghosting is a form of spite
I don't know that doesn't just be
indifference
apathy insens that develops feelings of
rejection and neglect ghosting has
adverse effects on the mental state of
the one being ghosted and although some
people earn it uh and his or her
emotional state that would be
interesting if they were like well we'll
review the communication and find out if
you actually deserve to be ghosting
there's actually no offense here they
have to do that right you can't just
blanket statement no you got to do both
sides speaking for the shittier side of
the two Sexes traditionally uh just on
murder rate alone some dudes deserve
yeah a lot of men deserve it look there
aren't a lot of moms that go out for a
pack of cigarettes and never come back
that's the ultimate go true that is true
classic yeah classic uh it has adverse
effects on on his or her emotional state
and is verely affected as he or she will
be constantly thinking of the welfare or
The Unexplained reasons of the one who
I'm getting a Vibe this guy got ghosted
big time well See's funny I first that's
where my mind went then I go what if he
is like the shoulder that has been
leaned on too hard by yes by a close
friend who has refuses to go to therapy
using him as the you know landing pad
and he's just done and like you cannot
ghost or you're going to be like my
stupid friend who I he's everybody's
amateur therapist so then he can then
say take it up with the law to his you
have a Le you have a legal leg to stand
on right now yeah yeah I'm helping you
so you don't have to bother me anymore
you don't have to call me anymore the
ambig the ambiguity which I'm proud of
myself for saying with ghosting is that
there is no real closure between the
parties concerned and as such it can be
likened to emotional cruelty and should
be punished as an emotional offense
because of the trauma it causes the
ghosted party unless they deserved it
that's right the bill was initially
proposed on June 30th this is a while
back we somebody could give us an update
uh and was read in the House of
Representatives on July 27th actually it
was left on red at the house of they
left it on red that's so awful did they
left on red it's currently pending the
government's health committee and is
unclear whether or not it will actually
pass forward the person writes in
parenthesis I bet it won't really you
didn't want to par wow that's injecting
something in there the bill also doesn't
stipulate what the penalty for the
ghosting will be and how the potential
law could be enforced well then come on
you haven't even fully written I feel
like this is we need but if anybody
wants to find out any of our boots on
the ground tell us want to find out like
but what would the penalty what would a
good penalty be before we get out here I
like the fine I'd say a fine just a if
you can prove it in court it should be
like a parking ticket fine
like exactly it has to be a number that
annoys you that you can afford but you
hate it you and you know that it doubles
in two months so but wait wait parking
fine goes to the government so does the
full amount of money go to the person
you've ghosted yes so the government
doesn't get any maybe the the government
can take because they were the the ones
who implemented it so I'll I I say they
can take 10% and then the rest my first
thought was that it should go to some
sort of service that helps people like
uh victims of domestic abuse but then I
thought the people would ghost and feel
good about it being like well at least
I'm donating so [__] it I'll go to this
person you can't go to something has to
go to something shitty that they're like
what if it went to refilling reservoirs
where government officials their way
love it we brought it back they have to
they you have to send the uh you have to
personally send the person you ghosted
through venmo so it has to send them a
message so now you are in this them and
then you have to check and see if they
got it you have that's part of the or
else the fine doubles the and if you got
ghosted and you respond with got the
money thank you what have you been up to
you have to send the money back to them
you can't you can't reinitiate yes yes
no it can't it is closed between the two
of you you can't even write it feels
good to see no to hear from you awesome
to hear from you I'm I I read about your
aunt in fact I'll even go a step further
and say that if they reach out the
person who ghosted you don't respond
give it back to them a little bit you
have to at least I think it's not an
emotional you're not an emotional
offender if you were the one who
initially had then you're you're just
you're just being responsible for your
own mob but you are allowed to like
start typing something so on their phone
they'll see the dot delete days days I
think they see the dots days dots for
days dots for days is underneath the can
we create an apps dots for days you
share location but it's not actually
yours so they think that they know what
you're up to and you're living a great
life can we create some app or something
that sends three dots that are moving
like that you're going to think and you
just do that and then disappear it
allows you to disappear it's D how has
no one created that and instead of three
dots it's three little ghost eyes like
from or or it goes for extra money it
will send something and within 2 seconds
undo send so that it the person just
sees Daniel vankirk unsent a message oh
God that's wor that's even wor that's
even because so good because you then
have to figure out a cool way to be like
what what were you what were you saying
what what did you send that you then had
to rec
nothing matter no they don't or they
don't respond to that yeah so good kid I
love it I really love how we're like
trying to put an end to ghosting but
then we're fully on board with revenge
and pettiness that is cool that's in our
scenario
exactly exactly everybody deserves
retaliation mindful retaliation I'll
make it a flowery term the way emal
offend that would be a great book too
mindful
retaliation we've already written so
many you guys are doing this book
together and you guys are lit agent this
I love it Jamie thank you so much I love
having you on this show you always make
everything great that you do love you
guys this is so fun and oh [__] we got
to get back to work we'll see
you sck around make a sound there's more
people
[Music]
town